[موسيقى]
اكثر من 100 يوم على هذه المشاهد جنود
قتلى مبان مدمره شوارع خاليه وفنادق تؤوي
الاف النازحين
الاسرائيليين سكان المناطق الشماليه
والجنوبيه مشاهد تثقل كاهل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي باتت تترنح ما بين
مواصله الحرب على غزه وضروره وضع خطه
اقتصاديه لتدارك حجم النفقات نفقات
وتكاليف تشير تقديرات وزاره الماليه
الاسرائيليه الى انها ستتجاوز حاجز ال 14
مليار دولار بحلول شهر
فبراير
[موسيقى]
رغم محاولات نتنياهو تسويق روايه لمواطنيه
وحلفائه السياسيين عنوانها اقتصاد اسرائيل
قوي ومستقر تندلع معارك في بنك اسرائيل
المركزي تظهر حجم التفاوت بين شاشات سوق
المال
والتصريحات اذ يطالب محافظ البنك المركزي
نتنياهو باتخاذ اجراءات تجنب الدخول في
ازمه اقتصاديه ح
[موسيقى]
اذا لم تتخذ الحكومه الاسرائيليه قرارات
واضحه في مجال الاقتصاد للسنه القادمه كما
يطالب محافظ بنك اسرائيل بروفيسور امير
يارون فالاقتصاد الاسرائيلي على حافه
الهاويه هناك خسائر كبيره في النمو
الاقتصادي في الاستثمار وفي مستوى المعيشه
للمواطن في
اسرائيل ملامح الازمه الاقتصاديه الحاده
تبدو تجلياتها واضحه في ابرز القطاعات
الاقتصاديه في البلاد تعد هذه العمارات في
مدينه تل ابيب شريان الاقتصادي الاسرائيلي
باحتوائه على اهم شركات التكنولوجيا
المتقدمه ويشكل القطاع التقني
18% من الناتج المحلي الاسرائيلي ونحو 50%
من الصادرات منذ بدء الحرب على غزه وعلى
اثر قرار التجنيد الواسع لقوات الاحتياط
خلت هذه الشركات من العمال لتواجه ازمه
اقتصا يه جديده ادت الى انخفاض
الاستثمارات بنحو 50% مقارنه بالعام
الماضي اخلاء بلدات غلاف غزه وتلك القريبه
من لبنان لم ينعكس فقط على التكاليف
المباشره للحرب بل تسبب بخسائر فادحه في
قطاع الزراعه حالت دون مد الاسواق باغلبيه
المحاصيل الزراعيه والمنتجات
الغذائيه واما قطاع البناء فشف على
الانهيار وفق ااد المقاولين الاسرائيليين
لاسباب عديده ابرزها غياب الايد العامله
الفلسطينيه منذ بدء
الحرب ولا يبدو قطاع السياحه افضل حالا
حيث تزامنت الحرب مع فتره الاعياد اذ شملت
الخسائر مختلف المناطق والقطاعات
[موسيقى]
السياحيه ما بين واقع تطرحه البيانات
والمعطيات الاقتصاديه التي تنثر بايام
صعبه على اقتصاد اسرائيل يبرز الدعم
الامريكي عاملا رئيسيا في تجنب مستقبل
كارثي على اقتصاد
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل الولايات المتحده تتعاون امنيا مع
اسرائيل والدعم هو دعم امني ومتبادل على
المستويين الاستخباراتي والتكنولوجي هناك
مصلحه امريكيه ان تكون اسرائيل قويه وذلك
من اجل استقرار
المنطقه تشير الارقام والبيانات من
المصادر الاسرائيليه الى ان استمراريه حرب
اسرائيل على غزه تعتمد على مدى صمود
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي المعتمد بشكل اساسي
على دعم الولايات المتحده اعتمادا تخشى
منه الاص الراغبه في استمرار الحرب داخل
حكومه نتنياهو ان يتحول الى اداه تكبح
جماح تل ابيب فاطمه خماسي الجزيره تل ابيب